emmy award-winning actor coleman domingo
congratulations how does it feel well
the way you just said it it feels really
good i haven't heard it just like that
but now i don't mind that moniker being
put on my name forever attached to your
name you are just such a standout talent
and then to be recognized for a standout
show like your work on euphoria what
does it mean
it means the world to me i think
euphoria is such a special show really
digging into um
some of the darkness and then
in our culture and how we're seeking the
light
it's dealing with everyone's struggles
whether it's um alcohol or you know some
narcotics you know you name it but i
feel like it's like it's something where
i think it's trying to heal the world in
many ways i think to unpack this stuff
together and you know sam writes very
simple you know conversations with
people to say yeah they're powerful and
saying you can get better and you to
reach out to someone and say hey i got
you and we're in this together it's
really awesome you and zendaya do such
heartbreakingly beautiful work together
in those scenes especially the the
special that you did that hour-long
special just the two of you having that
very honest dialogue back and forth what
is it about zendaya specifically that
makes you arrive at your best and
obviously help you win an emmy here
i think zendaya is such an open caring
kind artist
first and foremost i love working with
her she's funny she's super intelligent
and warm and so we just have an openness
with the way we play the way we i think
we have
sort of the same aesthetic in the way we
work you know what i mean i think we
both work hard i think privately we both
like probably put ourselves through
rigorous rehearsal and then we show up
available to each other i love working
with her and she's such an incredible
young woman and i love how she
represents other young women um she's
just awesome for sure yeah and uh and i
know that you guys have obviously
brought me to tears many times on screen
but i watched a blooper reel and i see
in a scene when the cameras are not
rolling you guys are like making each
other laughs yeah absolutely keeping it
light
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
i'm getting
asked what is the dynamic like on set
well you have to because i mean we're
dealing with such tricky troubled
dangers material and you know we got to
take the piss out of each other once in
a while you know what i mean really
is there is there a ritual or something
that you and zendaya do when you know
you're about to go do something very
heavy
no i think we're always chilling and
talking about photography and laughing
our conversations go all over the map
wow and then the moment sam says okay
and pictures up and action we're in it
wow yeah i love it i know season three
people have probably been bombarding you
with questions i am no different have
you seen scripts i have not seen one
script yet okay i have had um some small
conversations with sam and i know that
he's gonna take some uh big swings
because he's that kind of an artist i
think that he's like the moment you
you're comfortable with the show he's
got to pull the rug out from under you
just a little bit yeah and i think i
think he's going to find a way to do it
and do it with such um finesse and charm
oh and when you say big swings what does
that mean for ali
it does mean that he will be there
if he's showing up he's showing up but
it could be i don't know i think he's
very interested in he wants to make sure
that ali is not just that dude who comes
in who's going to say all the right
things yeah i think he wants to really
unpack ali a little bit too which is
great more of a backstory show some
backstory why not i feel like i would
like to see how ali got to become who
the guy he is in these diner scenes 100
he's got a lot of wisdom that man yeah
absolutely a lot of fans are really
interested in ali maybe getting a love
story in season three yeah rue's mom are
you are you interested in that i mean
nika king is kind of fine i mean why not
i mean i think we are sowing the seeds
already just a little bit so it could
could be a little something there you
know we recognize you know game
recognizes games there you go okay so
maybe a little a little lighter
trajectory lighter trajectory but also i
don't know i don't know what that would
do to zendaya's character because i'm
sure that's tricky for someone in
recovery to be like deal with her dad
who's your sponsor
but maybe that could be the mess that
could be interesting i love it i love it
back to your emmy really quick do you
know where this is gonna go
i think it's just it's gonna go my home
somewhere very special this is um hard
won and hard earned and many people um
have poured into me to have this so i
want to make sure it goes somewhere
special probably somewhere very in a
very sweet space in my home okay and
plans for celebration tonight
champagne champagne champagne lots of it
you need not say more you've earned it
and by the way this outfit is just
incredible this is a winner's outfit
this is dolce gabbana head to toe how
involved are you in selecting because
you show up fashion a game every single
time i'm very involved i collaborated
with that wayman and michael are my
stylists and we collaborated on this in
particular with dolce gabbana they um
micah even flew from venice with this
actually two nights ago in his arms to
make sure that we had this just right
and with working with taylor's and his
whole team they're just it's a team
effort so but i'm very much i'm a
collaborator i know exactly what how i
want to feel you know what i mean that's
if nothing else and how i want other
people to feel i want people to feel
like hopefully this makes people happy
when i walk into a room that's that's a
lot of my thought my thinking